all right mississippi is in real trouble
when it comes to the pandemic and they
are not messing around they are now
threatening uh five years in prison for
people who skip covet isolation
uh if it involves a life-threatening
situation so let's take a look at what
is going on here covet 19 patients must
isolate or face fines
under the new mississippi department of
health order
as covid 19 cases across the state
continue to surge state health leaders
are hoping a new order will encourage
people infected to self-isolate friday
state health officer dr thomas dobbs
handed down a mandate that all
individuals vaccinated or not who test
positive must stay home
upon learning they are infected
this is the key part individuals who
fail to do so could be charged with a
misdemeanor punishable by a fine of five
hundred dollars
six months imprisonment or both upon
conviction and then here's the key key
line
if a life-threatening disease is
involved
failure to follow the order could result
in a felony charge
carrying a fine of up to five thousand
dollars
five years in prison or both the news
comes as mississippi continues to report
thousands of new infections daily and as
it leads the nation in new cases per 100
000 inhabitants there are people saying
this is crazy this is too much but
understand what is happening in
mississippi
mississippi at baseline this is
pre-covered and during it just aside
from covid
mississippi is 50th out of 50
in healthcare rankings in the united
states this includes access cost and
quality okay
mississippi is also the second least
vaccinated state in the country they're
ahead of only alabama
and even then only by half a point
basically mississippi and alabama are
together the two least vaccinated states
in the country
mississippi is out of icu beds as of two
weeks ago
when dr leanne woodward tweeted there
were zero available icu beds in
mississippi as of early this morning
none that means hospitals across the
state may not be able to provide the
level of care needed to you or your
loved one
not just for
covid19 but for any emergency care
understand that this affects everybody
this effect put covet aside this affects
vaccinated people who get coveted and
unvaccinated people who get covered but
this affects people who just are driving
an activity that is not without risk and
you get into a serious car accident and
you need an icu
and the icu is full
overwhelmingly because of anti-vaxxers
who have coveted and are in an icu
uh or whatever it is that leads to you
being at the hospital the hospital will
be full
so yes mississippi is taking this
seriously they're saying you risk five
years in prison if you test positive and
don't isolate now meanwhile by the way
alabama hit negative 11 available icu
beds so
exactly what that means varies minus 11
could mean
they have 11 people who should be in the
icu but there's no room for them and
they're being somehow some other way
accommodated
or it could mean that they have gone
they've basically set up 11
kind of like emergency icu type beds
even though they're not really icu beds
regardless
negative icu availability is a very very
bad thing so that's what's going on in
mississippi that's what's going on in
alabama and increasingly we are seeing
children children hospitalized with the
virus so extremely serious stuff going
on and good for mississippi for doing
something